hello everybody high in the sky it's the
small white dot looming large the
Americans say this is a Chinese
surveillance balloon with a flight path
that's taken it over sensitive military
sites
the fact is uh we know that it's a
surveillance balloon and I'm not going
to be able to be more specific than that
we do know that the balloon has violated
U.S airspace and international law which
is unacceptable the balloon is believed
to have departed from mainland China and
was first sighted over the alician
islands near Alaska it's then thought to
have passed over Canada before being
sighted over Billings in Montana
nearby is malnstrom air base with 150
intercontinental ballistic missiles are
held
the U.S Air Force scrambled fighter jets
and surveillance aircraft upon
discovering the balloon which is the
size of three buses
the Americans decided against shooting
it down weary of danger from debris
falling on the ground and confident it
wasn't Gathering significant
intelligence but it casts a diplomatic
shadow
following a meeting with South Korea's
foreign minister the U.S Secretary of
State was due to fly to Beijing his
talks with President XI have now been
postponed once we detected the balloon
the US government acted immediately to
protect against the collection of
sensitive information
we communicated with the PRC government
directly through multiple channels about
this issue
we concluded that conditions were not
conducive for a constructive visit at
this time
China meanwhile has called the balloon a
civilian Airship used for research
mainly meteorological purposes it says
it regrets the unintended entry of the
Airship into U.S airspace
America begs to differ calling it
unacceptable and a violation of
sovereignty
I think the Chinese really were doing it
because they can
in response to long-standing use of
American spy planes up and down the
China coast and sometimes intruding into
a Chinese air space
the value of the Airship or balloon in
intelligence gathering terms probability
would be quite small it is that distant
spectacle in the Skies over the United
States with a sphere of influence that
extends far further
James Matthews Sky News in Washington